I almost picture it like the kid in the
class that finishes the test before
everybody else and walks out and
everybody looks around like wow how'd
they finished that so fast can we take
that same analogy with a new writer who
kind of says you know what I just want
to get my work out there I don't really
need all these drafts I know this is
good right you know it's possible
someone might be a savant of
screenwriting and able to do it
every great screenwriter that I've seen
and the ones who get the all the awards
they always say that it's taken them 30
40 drafts there is a top top one of the
most powerful show runners and telev in
hit television history and she said and
this might be an obvious thing to say
but she said you know a lot of people
say they want my life but they're not
willing to put in the hours and the
blood sweat and tears I have another
friend who's a top female showrunner and
I know the hours that she works and it's
not a 40-hour a week sometimes it's an
80 hour week
she's there's she loves her job and she
on weekends sometimes she'll be there
till midnight on a Friday and Saturday
working you know eight to 12 hours and
then the weekdays so the I think you
know look Mozart I think wrote his you
know come aceing compositions and he was
somewhat of a savant so I think it is
possible but I think something that gets
in the way is I understand the
enthusiasm and excitement to want to get
your script out there but there can be
may be either naivete or hubris and I've
noticed a lot there are times when the
writers are more and it could be the
same with an actor that they're more
focused on the end result and I know for
me as the producer and executive I'm
focused on the end result there's
nothing I want more than
to get made it is the greatest hi after
you've gone through all this work and
seeing it come to fruition and seeing
the set designer create the sets and
your actors you know actually performing
the lines and the scenes but if you look
at every wonderful writer director
filmmaker actor the trajectory of their
careers they started out like doing
little bit parts and movies that you
never would have thought they would wind
up one day getting an Oscar so it's at
each step is a is a part of the process
of the journey he's to say whether they
get someone like Kathryn Bigelow you
know when she started out or patty
Jenkins for example when Cuddy did
monster and I think she had gone to AFI
she just kept doing good work these are
people just kept doing good work I don't
think that you know patty Jenkins
thought when she was at AFI oh I'm gonna
do an indie film called monster and get
an Oscar for the leading actress and I'm
then gonna go and do Wonder Woman
superhero and be the first woman to
woman to you know break all box office
records as a director Barry Jenkins when
he did moonlight I don't think he was
doing it because he thought oh I'm gonna
get an Oscar I think he wanted to he was
compelled to tell a story and he told it
beautifully and it affected and
resonated you know with so many people
so I think the most important thing for
writers directors actors is to stay
committed to the craft and just doing
the best work that you can and surround
yourself with people who can give you
really constructive feedback even if
it's not always what you want to hear
but to be open to feedback that can be
constructive and make you a better
writer do you think that's a factor of
age do you think younger people really
want to rush to it or it's not about
that it could bear
in my experience it's not about that
because I know older writers who you
know they filmed like times not on their
side so that they actually in some ways
can be in more of a rush than younger
writers that's true yeah
when you see a writer that you know that
they do have talent you can see that it
just maybe needs a little more refining
and you need to slow them down what are
some of the things that you do first I
don't like to ever feel that I'm in the
position to like slow so I went down
most of what I do is just ask questions
if in the script there are there's a
plot aspects or character behavior
that's not clear to me or confusing or
inconsistent I'll just ask the question
and I always tell the writer that they
never to feel compelled to agree with me
it's not a dictatorial thing but it is
for the purpose of I feel I'm a pretty
good barometer of what other how other
executives are are going to respond to
material and if it's not clear to me
then there's a good chance that it might
not be clear to someone else so they
don't have to I never feel like I want
to impose something to be done a certain
way but I will race a question or I'll
say I feel that this dialogue
it doesn't feel authentic to me it feels
like there's an agenda the writer has an
agenda that you want the character to
say this but I think if we're really
looking in the scene and a daughter is
responding to her mother how much she
really respond and I'll ask the writer
to go back and kind of try and find the
truth rather than the written agenda if
that makes sense so so I think it's
really more about asking questions and
pointing out areas that can be improved
rather than slow down I'm like if you
think it's ready to go and you're happy
with and you don't agree then by all
means you should pursue that but I think
a lot of times there can be a tendency
to take something out too hastily
do you think people are aware of that
how damaging that can be because if they
get consistent coverage it just kind of
like labels that one project or even
their name it's not ready you're yeah
and I'm getting let's say oh yeah
because here's the thing is so you have
a lot of people writers will be focused
on networking which is great networking
is important let's say you meet someone
it's a producer and they say quit send
me your script and it's not very good
you have a frozen moment in time to have
that capture that person's attention and
if they don't respond to it or they have
an assistant who reads it and says
because a lot of times it is what
happens and says it wasn't very good the
next time you want to get something in
they might not be as inclined to to read
your work you know tell them it's the
past we've the the writing was just not
up to snuff it was very amateurish the
person doesn't even know how to write a
script to be honest there are certain
things that there is classic formatting
but there's also certain telltale signs
such as if there's dialogue on the page
that takes up half a page or almost the
whole page that's a telltale sign of
with exception of course there are
always exceptions but that would be a
sign that it's an amateur if there's
pages in a script that are so dense that
it looks like a novel that would be
another sign if there's like page after
page of in very dense descriptions that
will wind up in and the recycle bin or
the trash in the your computer so
you